so then what made you settle on
Christianity over anything else like
ultimately the historicity of the
Resurrection I became convinced I mean I
think that I mean officers agree that
Jesus is a real person who existed in
history you know and when you follow
these sort of objective kind of
standards and methods that they use in
order to come to historical facts I
think that when you do that you come
across a lot of facts that I think is
only explained by the fact that Jesus
actually did raise from the dead and so
for me that was like the thing where I
spent a lot of time thinking about it
too like trying to run it around in my
head trying to like argue it with myself
and with other people and so on and that
just slowly became more convinced of it
and I kind of got to the point where I
realized that Christianity makes the
most sense of all of reality